I want to talk to you about psychedelics
because when did you first do them when
I was thirty near 30 actually I think I
was a little younger no yeah yeah when I
was 30 I started smoking pot and then
psychedelics came after that and did you
I mean obviously that that was before
the time when people thought
psychedelics were a way to like
heal yourself like I feel like this is
kind of like a new movement that
psychedelics are the answer if you
around the right people suck and you
would get that information yeah yeah I
was around a lot of I because of the
fact that I was a comedian and then also
because of the fact that you know I was
relatively famous back there not not
famous famous but like Pete I was I was
on television I've done some things so
people would want to like turn you on to
things you know I can't you know and I
would go to parties or meet people and
they would you know say hey man have you
ever done mushrooms you know and a hey
man you've heard of DMT and like and
then there's a few different things that
would happen and you would be around
these people who had gone to jail for it
or you know that we're like real
psychedelic heads and once I was around
a few of those I realize like well
there's a whole nother world out there
and then I discovered Timothy Leary and
John Lilly and thus the floatation tank
became a giant part of my life and then
you know Terence Mckenna and Dennis
McKenna and all the the various
psychedelic wizards that are out there
that have been sort of expressing that
there's there's a whole world out there
that you're not seeing it's like we're
living life inside this very strange
tent there's a very thin membrane tent
and if you just unzip that tent and step
out the entire wilderness of the
universe exists but most people live
their life inside this very thin walled
tent and they think that that tent sort
of defines the actual universe itself
when it's it's so small and so limited
is there a chance that you open that
tent you don't like what you see and now
you [ __ ] your whole life
because I think that's most people's
apprehension about sure doing that like
specific and you not come back yes
little sid barett you know there's been
a lot of people that were I mean I have
friends that know friends that well the
issue is with you know psychosis and
people that have schizophrenia people
that have like legitimate mental mental
health issues and it's did the argument
is correlation or causation right and
the argument is does the psychedelic
drugs cause mental illness or do a
certain amount of people already have
mental illness and I think it's much
more likely that the percentage of
people that are schizophrenic remains
static because if you if you look at it
like this the number of people who smoke
marijuana who are also schizophrenic
mirrors the number of people or
schizophrenic period so it's not that
marijuana causes schizophrenia such that
one out of a hundred or whatever the
number is they just have this issue this
this and for those people it's critical
that they avoid psychedelic drugs that
they avoid marijuana and and probably
even alcohol or many even maybe a bunch
of other psychotropic drugs as well
because it could you've got an imbalance
just like someone who has a liver
disease has an imbalance just like
someone who has a lung disorder can't
breathe well someone has cystic fibrosis
or someone who has any number of
diseases you got to kind of think of it
that way yeah there's an ailment of the
mind and so if you add this unknown
element to that ailment like five grams
of dried mushrooms like whoa who the
[ __ ] knows what could happen you might
never come back and then there's the
question the other part of your question
is is it possible you could open that
tent and not like what you see and [ __ ]
up your life yes yes even if you don't
have schizophrenia or a mental disorder
you might have a view of the world
that's untenable with the experience
that you have under the influence of
psychedelics but that might mean that
your view of the world is [ __ ]